[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily what we saw was an
affront not only to our democracy but
also to our values the search is on for
individuals accused of storming the u.s
capitol
our experts weigh in on the possible
charges they could be facing
what happened is textbook terrorism
a religious leader accused of sexual
assault appears in court
the secret weapon prosecutors have for
this upcoming trial
my client has actually always wanted to
plead guilty and expose the church
plus a hearing continues for the
so-called doomsday cult couple
the secret recording that led laurie
valo and chad dabo to requesting their
prosecutors be removed
we are going to be filing conspiracy to
commit murder charges
it is full chat and glory law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
[Music]
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
local dc officials are speaking out
after riders stormed the u.s capitol
and are apparently planted at least two
explosive devices
there were 68 individuals arrested
yesterday evening and into
into the early morning hours of january
7th
of the 68 arrests 60 were adult males
and eight were adult
females 41 of those arrests occurred on
u.s capitol grounds and to my knowledge
only one of the restes
is from the district of columbia i just
want to underscore that only one of the
arrestees was from the district
of columbia however we still have a
significant amount of work ahead of us
to identify and hold each and every one
of the violent mob accountable for their
actions
we have collected numerous images of
persons of interest
that we are asking the community to help
us identify
these images depict individuals engaged
in various acts of violence
or property destruction and we have made
these images
available on our website and social
media
platforms the fbi is also calling for
help to identify individuals
investigating violence in washington d.c
anyone with tips is asked to go to
fbi.gov u.s capital
police say four people died one inside
the capitol after being shot by police
and three of medical emergencies
metropolitan police department is
handling the investigation of the u.s
capitol police officer-involved shooting
that occurred in the house lobby area
the decedent in that shooting has been
identified as 35-year-old
ashley pomitan also known as ashley
babbitt of huntington maryland
this remains an active mpd investigation
there were three additional deaths that
occurred which we believe all to be the
results of medical emergencies
the decedents have been identified as
50-year-old benjamin phillips of
ringtown pennsylvania
55-year-old kevin greason of athens
alabama
and 34 year old roseanne boylan of
kennesaw
georgia joining us now is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi along with
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
and terry austin gene
charges have been set but only so far
for gun possession and being out after
curfew many
are asking about actual charges stemming
from storming the capital destroying
property
sedition theft and even the monuments
and statues act
what do you make of the charges and lack
thereof
well in terms of making of the charges
in dc there are two
uh courts if you will there's dc
superior court
which is the state crimes and that's for
trespassing destruction
of property and then there's the big
court there's the u.s district court
and what i think is going on here by the
charges brought and the lack of charges
is this
they're charging all these lower level
people in dc superior court
with relatively i say relatively minor
crimes
compared to what the big charges could
be in federal court
and in federal court they're going to
bring the big guns
you're going to have federal conspiracy
to commit uh sedition
uh insurrection interfere with elections
and that'll be the grand jury process
you are gonna see a
flurry of subpoenas through various
individuals
in the white house in in the police
department
in other areas the individuals the lower
levels
their facebook defined this was there a
conspiracy
among major people including the
president
giuliani to conspire to
cause a riot if you will at the u.s
capitol
which violates so many crimes i don't
even want to mention
one so that's what it tells me about the
charges brought
and the charges not brought they're
going to be moving up the food chain
and you could possibly see in a year or
two a major
ricoh indictment in u.s district court
that's my take
now that's for the people who protested
and and rioted
inside of the capitol now gigi ashley
babbitt as we heard she was shot and
killed in the capital
could there be charges against the
officer that killed her
terry what about what do you think about
when it comes to ashley babbitt could
there be charges against
the officer who killed her i don't think
so brian because
if you think about it the capital was
being
charged this woman was being hoisted
over
the window and the security guards in
the capital had to defend the capital
so they pulled their guns out and one of
them did shoot and they did not know
whether or not there were weapons that
were being brought in maybe she had a
weapon so
i think that she you know was killed and
it's
horrible that anybody got shot and
killed but i think that the officer who
pulled the trigger
is going to be able to justifiably
defend himself as far as that death was
concerned now gg when i saw some of the
social media the
defense attorney into me was screaming
because there's so many photos of these
individuals there's going to be a bee on
the lookout
one guy had his feet on nancy pelosi's
desk and was posing
uh what do you think's gonna happen to
people like him
oh he's gonna get the book thrown at him
and not only that some of these people
actually filmed themselves and posted
the own evidence of their crime on their
social media platforms
as a criminal defense attorney you're
looking at this and it's like how
dumb do you have to be to commit this
type of crime on
international television and here they
are um this is a criminal defense
attorney's nightmare to defend some of
these people
yeah i'm not looking forward to that if
i was representing these guys
and in other top news a hearing is
underway for the four former police
officers
charged in the droid floyd case the
ex-cops including derek shovin are
requesting their trial be delayed from
march
until this summer prosecutors are not
objecting the ex-cops are also seeking
to introduce new evidence that
investigators found drugs in floyd's
vehicle
nearly seven months after his death
floyd was killed in may after the
officers kneeled on his neck for more
than eight minutes
recording is not allowed of the virtual
hearing for the long crime network is
following
and will bring you the latest still
ahead on long crime daily could the
doomsday cult couple finally be facing
charges for the deaths of their two
children
but first a hearing for a former head of
church accused of sexually assaulting
his own followers our exclusive report
next
[Music]
a religious leader accused of sexually
assaulting his follower is expected to
go to trial
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross has an exclusive report on
why one of his own members plans to
testify against him
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
a year of reckoning for yet another
powerful man accused of
abusing the young woman under his
control and authority
he calls himself the apostle joaquin
garcia
leads the light of the world church
claiming 5 million members in the u.s
and around the world he's set to go to
trial in california
in the next few months and among those
testifying against them will be the
woman who was once his handmaiden
she's pled guilty she can't talk yet
publicly but she wants the world to know
what she knows about the apostle
it's quite clear that three generations
of garcias have been engaging
in rampant sexual abuse and pedophilia
and lately uh child pornography and yet
they maintain this this image
of holiness and purity people are now
starting to
starting to see them for what they are
and uh my client mrs ocampo wants to
play a role in that
she wants to expose them and and
actually
one of the reasons she's asked me to be
her spokesperson is is
she wants to hopefully prevent these
abuses from occurring to other women
it took her a long time to realize that
what was being done to her
was not holy was not righteous
was not something mandated by
by god and um she's hoping that other
women who are or were in the same
situation she was in will
will see this and um
hopefully we'll will learn that this
abuse isn't right
that's coming up this week i'm bryan
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network brian
thanks brian garcia briefly appeared in
los angeles county court as his case
prepares for trial
for matters and trial setting that is
day zero
of 45. uh defending garcia is filed this
day
a motion to compel discovery um
he was served is that correct yes yeah
sure
and the council told me importantly that
they agreed on the date of february
10 2021 uh
for hearing the worship of hell is that
mr jackson yes yes
mr perry
back with me our attorneys gigi gonzalez
and terry austin terry
the co-defendant already pled guilty to
i think four sexual assaults of minor
charges felonies all of them
and plans to testify against garcia is
this all but
done deal for garcia now you know brian
it's definitely
not going to help his case when you have
someone who is
testifying against you they know all of
the details
and apparently ocampo the woman who is
you know his co-defendant she has been
described as this
handmaiden so she actually has had
sexual
abuse herself and apparently she was
working and
grooming the girls who were involved in
this sexual abuse case it sounds a
little bit
if you ask me like uh maxine you know
delon maxwell so i don't know but it
does seem as though that it could be
very damaging yeah definitely a lot of
similarities with the elaine maxwell
and epstein casey now gg i get it
defense attorneys you got to make your
defense but this whole
someone put child porn on my laptop
sounds a lot like a dog ate my homework
what do you make of this potential
defense uh the defense is putting
forward
isn't that so convenient for this man
who's been accused of
serious sexual abuses and child
pornography
oh that's i don't have it no people
planted it onto my personal phone and
devices
and they also manufacture the child
pornography and put it on
next he's going to say that they also
forced him to keep that on his devices
and to not report the incident to law
enforcement you know that defense is
pretty transparent and i don't believe
that any jury is going to
put a lot of weight into it yeah i
thought the shaggy it wasn't me defense
was pretty bad but this one i don't know
how it's going to work out
um terry when we're looking at this case
do you see the prosecution having a
simple path to
conviction or do you see some pitfalls
in their case
you know it looks fairly straightforward
to me brian i think if in fact they
do have the co-defendant who is
testifying against him
the jury is going to be quickly led to
the fact that you know this is a done
deal they have
the evidence as far as the computers are
concerned and like gigi said you know i
don't think the jury is going to believe
that someone else was in his technology
frankly yeah and the fact that the uh
co-defendant was already pled guilty
it's kind of hard to make that argument
that hey you're only doing this for a
reward that might already be done
coming up on law and crime daily the
newly released secret recording in the
doomsday cult couple
we have it for you next
attorneys for a couple accused of
concealing the bodies of two children
want the prosecutor thrown off their
case
lori vale and her husband chad dabell
charge in connection with the deaths of
valo's two children
the bodies of seven-year-old j.j valo
and 16-year-old tylie ryan
were found buried in a shallow grave in
davao's idaho property
the couple was arrested last year in
hawaii but neither are facing murder
charges
long crimes executive trial producer
kathy russon
breaks down what's behind the latest
arguments in the case
there's a lot to unwrap here a few
months ago in october of 2020
rob wood went to arizona with what he
says was an introductory meeting
with lori valodevil's sister summer
shiplet
rob wood says he went down there at the
request of
summer's attorney garrett smith who is
representing both ladies not that
they're charged with anything but they
have
representation he recorded the
conversation then garrett smith claims
that
it bothered him some things that rob
woods said in that conversation
and so he decided to turn the recording
over to mark
means lori valos attorney
and that's where this all came about
when mark means heard
information on that tape he filed a
motion to disqualify
prosecutor rob wood saying that he
unduly influenced he coerced
manipulated material witnesses
and the prosecutors heard on the
recording telling valo's sister he plans
to find
file conspiracy to commit murder charges
against the couple
our goal is to have such a strong case
that when she has confident counsel i
don't know if he knows her attorney's
never handled a felony before
um he has never
never done any meaningful criminal work
at all
and he doesn't know what he's doing he's
a nice guy
yeah he's lying about me but he uh
but he's he doesn't know what he's doing
and one
once we file further charges she will be
appointed
counsel who will know what they're doing
and our goal is to
put together such a case that they're
smart enough to say uh
it's gonna be better to talk so i i'm
so torn with all of it's such a
conflicting feeling to know that this
person's been good her whole life and
then has made this error in judgment
and got accepted into this vortex of
this man
and i feel for her
i just have so much compassion towards
her because i know that's not what
she would have ever done on her own and
so she paid the price for this
forever and i hate that for her so i'm
very
conflicted but i was going to ask you on
the concealment
or not the concealment but on the
conspiracy to commit murder
what's the weight of that in terms of
joseph is that a death penalty thing or
it is a death penalty
do you are you planning to ask for that
for them or do you we sure hope we don't
a lot of that will depend on her
and when we come back a closer look into
the courtroom arguments in this hearing
for chad and lori dabo our experts weigh
in after the break
back now to the case of the doomsday
cult duel and their defense's motion to
disqualify the prosecutor
terry austin covered the hearing on the
matter and has a latest on this
brian the defense hired a forensic
psychologist to review
a recording of a meeting between the
prosecutor and laurie vallo's sister
laurie vallo and chad dabell are charged
with hiding the bodies
of valo's two children they are not
charged with murder and their defense is
fighting the pending charges
against them in a meeting with valo's
sister that was secretly recorded
the prosecutor is heard saying he plans
to file
conspiracy to commit murder charges now
the defense is accusing the prosecutor
of intimidating valo's sister their
expert says the prosecutor tried to
solicit
specific answers from the sister that
would agree with the state's theory
the conclusion i had was that
this would be a type of bias that i call
inner circle bias
and circle bias is a situation where
witness is provided with
uh information that's not known to the
general public
and so uh it's an effort to include the
witness
in sort of the inner circle uh of
information
and uh as a result it can be
uh co-opting of that person uh
to to really join whatever that inner
circle
is uh so that would be the the bias that
i
believe was active in that particular
interchange
and the interchange is where he talks
about um
seeing the kids in yellowstone and then
the his decision of telling this
shiftlet
that he's going to file murder charges
against chad and laurie is that correct
that's correct
on cross-examination an attorney for rob
wood
pointed out that the defense's expert
was coming to these conclusions
without speaking to schifflett directly
i haven't uh you know followed this case
in the media and so forth and so on
i think i was referring and reacting
more to the sense of
the way the information was given but
that to your point i i
do not have a way to demonstrate to you
that i don't know that it's not public
well i appreciate the answer because i i
mean clearly you haven't talked with
summershiflet right
i have not you haven't watched the
preliminary hearing
i have not um i didn't see you president
preliminary hearing is that right
correct um and so that's that
my concern when you're talking inner
circle and biases and things known to
the public
um you don't know what's out in the
public right
correct if i may though inner circle is
not necessarily something that
means it's not in the public it is a
biased effort to
draw somebody into an inner circle
my panel is back with me gigi this could
be more than just
trying to get the prosecutor out because
if they get a prosecutor out could they
potentially make an argument that the
information
that the prosecutor collected should be
thrown out too
yeah absolutely especially if they're
successful in getting the prosecutor
removed
and that's a really hard feat to
overcome but if they are
if they are able to prove that the
prosecutor roy wood
acted illegally and outside of the
bounds of
his position then i think it would make
sense to also exclude any evidence that
the prosecutor collected
while on that illegal pursuit now terry
you were very fascinated as a as was i
but the science behind what they were
saying that the prosecutor was doing
when talking to these two people
as kind of picking up where gg left off
if they are successful the defense is
successful in this how do you see this
playing out for the rest of the trial
if some of this information doesn't come
in you know it's very
interesting brian this witness dr james
davidson
talked about the fact that wood
specifically was trying to lead
summer and influence her and coerce her
into saying certain things
he used words like confirmatory bias and
he said that
she was being solicited to acquiescence
and
you know he was using the read technique
and i think that if in fact
he is dismissed from the case and he
can't prosecute this any longer
and if in fact somehow summer's
testimony is
limited i think it will affect the case
and
frankly i think at the end of the day
the judge is going to say
that there was no wrongdoing with this
18-minute recording that we heard
and that wood might have said a little
more than he should have
but it wasn't prosecutorial misconduct i
agree wholeheartedly
with gigi that he was in fact within the
bounds of what he could have asked her
during this little 18-minute meet and
greet and i guess that's my final
question for you terry
because i agree with you but i agree
with you because the law says that but
do you think the science does
i don't think the science says that i
mean i think at the end of the day
it's gonna stay in all right thank you
ng and terry and thank you for joining
us here at long crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you